I am laughter Reuben according to Star
Wars name generator' for fun calm and
many Bothans died to bring you this
information so be sure to LIKE and
subscribe so their deaths were not in
vain man how much time did we spend on
this way to wall in news that proves
people aren't all terrible a man has
scored himself a free trip to Blizzcon
for being a good human last month reddit
user commerce 49 was trawling eBay as
you do and bought a storage unit that
contained a bunch of Blizzard stuff in
said stuff was this CD labeled Starcraft
a gold master source code thankfully he
did not chuck it out for use it as a
coaster and instead took to Reddit where
he was encouraged to upload the files
online for everybody
Blizzard came across his account and
asked that he returned the disk instead
which he ended up doing in return
Blizzard through a free copy of
overwatch his way along with 250 bucks
in blizzards store credit and all
expenses paid trip to Blizzcon and a
night out for drinks among other things
let me know what you would have done in
that situation in the comments call of
duty black ops 3 is getting some new dlc
this month in the form of zombie
chronicles studio head at Treyarch jason
blundell told youtuber JC backfire the
map pack will include eight zombie maps
from past track developed Call of Duty
games he said those early storyline
concepts of those early concepts that
really set down the foundation of
zombies a lot of people hadn't
experienced them you'll be able to
survive the undead horde on nakta on
totin kino der toten worked and she no
Numa from world of war shangri-la moon
and ascension from black ops and origins
from black ops 2 zombie Chronicles is
due out for ps4 on May 16 no date has
been announced for Xbox one and PC but
DLC packs typically arrive about a month
later on those platforms
finally in things that are dumb and MD
Davis had to change the name of their
game in order to avoid a legal battle
with Bethesda's parent company indie
game prayed for the gods spelled like
this has had to change its name to pray
for the gods spelled like this the
developer no matter
Judeo said in a blog post they made the
change to avoid a legal battle with
ZeniMax Bethesda who would contest the
trademark over their game prey they
explained something like a trademark
opposition can be long and depending on
how fast someone wants to fight it can
be very expensive we didn't want to
spend our precious Kickstarter funds and
nor did we want to have to ask for
additional funds to fight this in court
with those two marketing boss Pete Hines
weighed in on Twitter that the company
took action to maintain control of its
prey trademark he said we really didn't
have much of a choice if we don't oppose
the mark we risk losing our prey
trademark we don't really have a choice
so maybe it's the system at fault here
let me know what you think in that
comment box that is everything I've got
for you today do remember that we've got
our top 5 stories of the whole week
coming up for you tomorrow
and may the force be with you